One of the things I've been talking about for a
few weeks now is what I see as the underselling of
the coronavirus vaccines as something that could
well be making people less interested in getting
vaccinated. When you see endless headlines about
even if you're vaccinated, you can't do anything
differently. You can't hang out with people you
can't do indoors. You have to wear a mask. You
can't travel. You can't visit anybody. All of
this different stuff. And we've been expecting
new guidelines from the CDC in conjunction with
the dramatically accelerating vaccination numbers
that we talked about yesterday. And we got it.
The big news to skip to sort of the meat of the
announcement is that the CDC now says vaccinated
people can safely gather indoors without masks,
with other vaccinated people, without social
distancing. You can hug vaccinated. People can
also be with unvaccinated people if the
unvaccinated people are of low risk. And
there's a few other things. Let's look at CDC
Director Wollensky telling us this yesterday.
CDC recommends that fully vaccinated people
can visit with other fully vaccinated people
in small gatherings indoors without wearing
masks or physical distancing. Remember,
here we are talking about private settings where
everyone is vaccinated. So what does this mean? If
you and a friend or you and a family member are
both vaccinated, you can have dinner together
wearing masks without distancing. You can visit
your grandparents if you have been vaccinated
and they have been, too. Now, I want to talk to
you about another, more complicated scenario.
It involves vaccinated people visiting with
unvaccinated people when fully vaccinated
people visit with unvaccinated people. We have to
consider the underlying risks of the unvaccinated
people and any unvaccinated members of their
household. We take this approach because all
of our guidance is rooted in making sure we are
keeping people safe. So CDC recommends that fully
vaccinated people can visit with unvaccinated
people from one other household indoors without
wearing masks or physical distancing
as long as the unvaccinated people and
any unvaccinated members of their household are
not at high risk for severe covid-19 disease.
So additionally, vaccinated people can gather
indoors, unmasked with unvaccinated people from
the same household, assuming that the unvaccinated
people are low risk. So the point here is
the vaccines are extremely effective, essentially
100 percent effective at preventing serious covid
and death and they appear to reduce transmission.
More on that in a moment. And on this basis,
it is time for certain elements to start
going in the direction of renormalization. Now
vaccinated people should not go hang out with
a high risk eighty five year old unvaccinated
person. Fortunately, increasingly, a majority of
those over 60 have now been vaccinated, at least
with one shot in the United States majority.
Not all, to put it a different way. Vaccinated
grandparents can visit unvaccinated healthy kids
and grandkids, but vaccinated kids should not be
visiting unvaccinated grandparents. I will be
paying very close attention to this household
thing, being vaccinated myself, my girlfriend
being vaccinated. I have friends who are couples
and work from home who aren't yet vaccinated. That
seems safe and that's in accordance with what the
CDC says to couples from different households,
especially if one doesn't work from home. I'm not
going to get into that kind of situation for the
foreseeable future. So this is a big step forward.
The science seems increasingly clear
on how effective these vaccines are
at preventing death. Serious illness increasingly
clear that they also reduce transmissibility,
although that's still being studied. The CDC
said yesterday a, quote, growing body of evidence
suggests people who are vaccinated are not only
less likely to have asymptomatic infections,
but also potentially less likely to transmit
the virus. Still, they aren't ruling out the
possibility that a vaccinated person could
inadvertently transmit the virus. We're
going to learn more about that over the coming
weeks and months. Also from the CDC yesterday,
vaccinated people don't need to quarantine or get
tested if they have a known exposure to the virus,
assuming they don't develop symptoms. So this
would be you find out someone you work with if
you're working in an office, someone you work
with has tested positive you were vaccinated.
You do not need to go through an isolation and.
Quarantine protocol, if you are vaccinated,
unless you develop a symptom vaccinated, people
should be avoiding large and medium gatherings.
Still, everybody should. And of course, none of
these guidelines change anything for vaccinated
people out in public. If a grocery store says
masks, then everyone wears masks. Regardless of
vaccination state status, that should be obvious.
That makes absolute perfect sense. So hopefully
and we're going to have a very interesting
interview later today with Jonathan Berman about
the vaccine hesitancy, which is fortunately
waning in the United States on the covid vaccine.
Hopefully, this increases the number of people
who get vaccinated, since the more that that
do get vaccinated, number one, the more
people that can get into this new protocol
outlined by the CDC, but also the faster we can go
to the next step of relaxation of guidelines. Now,
some states are just relaxing all
guidelines now, Texas, Mississippi,
some others scheduling. Further relaxation is
going to wide open everything. No masks anywhere.
I believe that there will be people who will
want the vaccine because now it's in black
and white from the CDC. You get vaccinated
and your parents do. You can hang out and
you can hug. And these are things that many
people in parts of the country haven't done
for really almost a year. We're about a week from
the one year mark from the Trump announcement that
travel from certain countries is being banned and
sort of the beginning of quarantines for those
who have been doing them. That's what's going
on in terms of what vaccinated people can do.
Let's now go to our weekly covid update as to the
numbers which continue to improve. Fortunately